the video of a drag queen being hauled
out of a bar in handcuffs would go a
long way towards throwing a little
gasoline I honestly think the manager of
the establishment that facilitated a sex
show for children should be brought out
wearing their nice little button-up
shirt and tie with their pens in their
pocket being like I don't understand why
I'm being arrested I operate an
establishment and then as they're being
brought out the police can say he
operated a sex show for children and
they'll go whoa jail and make sure that
the inmates that he shares that he
shares uh another jail with make sure
they know because I don't care about any
of that weird stuff man just
have him register as a sex offender and
that see that's a huge threat right
there because if they're not doing
anything no that did but that's a great
one that's a great tool right there